this week we are partnered with hellofresh
and Rocket money more on them after the
reaction yo citizens of the reject Nation we
have made it to episode three of hasb been
Hotel I just changed into a sweater we were
watching this moments after episode two Roxy
went to the bathroom she had some crackers
good make sure you tell them I went to the
bathroom if you don't tell them how will they
watch the rest I believe in authenticity and
open communication I do keep eating crack
yeah before the show then the whole show
I'm like this yeah me too I got some in my
mouth as well hey what do you guys think of
hasman Hotel subscribe and click that Bell to
get notified when our reaction for four is up
here on the channel leave a like while you're at
it too thank you to prepper I think bring down
these highlights it's episode three I'm in the
middle of this intro Jesus woman you're right
hey I got a got a quick question for you no when
you're right you're right yes it's episode three
but it's like the fourth one I just didn't want
them to get confused they won't be and uh full
length Reaction watch a longer you see with
your own copy Pass Hotel super sexy rejects
our patreon page thank you to all have joined
I'm assuming you have I can see into the future
cover several things over there exclusive has
watch long included I'm ready you ready let's
get this show out the road y ready for this I
like the husband husband I like the husband h
looks perfect I am so excited that sir penus is
staying at the hotel this is more than a warm
welcome penus was just trying to take over the
city with his weird steampunk [__] a few days
ago I haven't seen him try to pull any of that
here what's the passage of time here hello purple
female my new invention was it a dude I know
last episode had her and a guy looking forward
to shooting the other residents why everyone
is being too nice obviously it must be a lie
they are planning to kill me but when how I must
be prepared cuz he's never had love before I get
your bad thank you for your business enjoy your
Carmine purchase as in Carmela Carmine you are
buying parts from an Overlord Carmine ultimate
Overlord name she's the top weapons dealer in
Hell okay well that stops right now not to be
sexist but there too many women in Hell there's
not that many evil women it's an objective fact
first you get female representation now you're
complaining about the female representation yep
you have to trust us but I don't why don't we
focus on that for today's activities no more
building weapons no more plotting against
other guests and you need to get rid of these
things egg egg and eggy not my little egg boys
they do my evil bidding for me do you want to
stay here and redeem yourself yes yes then no
more eggs all right Eggies a he's really just so
soft no don't resist this is how it has to be so
theatrical oh my
god oh ew oh no I'm in the middle of breakfast
penis's eggs are all over the place and I need
you to get rid of them what does a hell
deer taste like well in that case I'd be
delighted to humanely that's a lot less hot
but I suppose I can take care of that on my
outing today I'm obsessed with Alistair and
the quality of his voice is just crazy cool
we think that this group could really benefit
from trust exercis excises trust exercises are
hard let's get started Charlie AC actually I
thought maybe you could take the lead on this
one oh boy I trust everyone so maybe you'd know
better about how to build it properly I trust
everyone so you know how to build it but who does
she trust outside of Charlie but well she's got
to learn starting with trust Falls each of you
are going to share something vulnerable with
the group about yourself and then fall backwards
while the rest of the group catches you got it
that is a hard hard to watch Harley all right
get on up here I she going to hit the ground I
love you guys no no no she'll be caught really
love you gotcha Angel why don't you go next
fine this time everyone needs to catch him okay
unless you want me to hurt you incentive I love
to suck I swear if you say popsicles you sicko I
also love popsicles recently hey but you know to
they all CAU I'm dropped them I don't want to live
without my minions nobody catch me damn it that's
great sometimes I kill mother bugs in front of
their children is a warning to others oh God yay
pain pain oh my God I don't know this is
really working the way we hoped I got this
okay I'll figure something out Charlie having
a trust exercise with her friend are you're
not getting a relationship Vibes still no not
yet can I touch your staff thing are those your
ears or is it your hair I can't tell how fa
this day oh my God greetings vestial W holy
[__] the weather nothing become this fine day
who looks like we might have some acid rain this
afternoon oh I just took a well- earned sabatical
nothing serious though it's fun to keep everyone
on their toes now he's got a master plan rol by
far to assume the workings of your mind Alister
thou been not since thy manifested in this realm
feels truly ancient now stay here and guard the
front until I return this guy really feels like
straight out of some type of actual like evil lore
like the way he's portrayed he's not portrayed
in a comedic way Frank is up there we have
names good henchmen High
Society yeah what is the societal breakdown in
hell I'm interested this is true how do you get
higher in class like what is the strongest
commodity how do you gain power this year's
extermination was bual we have assessed that
about 16% of the population was lost 16 twice
as quickly I think it prudent we it's giving
leftovers kisses darling nice of you to join
us velvet will your colleagues be joining no they
have better [__] to do than to listen to an old
windbag who thinks she's tough [__] I'm here
to represent oh gosh you guys aren't going to
succeed with this why cuz they're women no that
wasn't what I was really thinking where did you
get this we found it during extermination day
if these holy rollers can be killed the game
has changed can take the fight to them I would
not do that if it be true thee and my colleagues
desire to war with such me proof Thou Art far
more foolish than I be thought yeah that would
not do that it's a deading Exorcist you going
blind old man they planted him mayhaps was
not by a demon's hand at all if we rush to war
without knowing might they Purge all of hell for
deing and Uprising I love the way his dialogue
is heard yeah that was planted saw so grandpa
is tooy to fight so I guess there's no point
oh what's the mat of fossil to scile to make
a real power grab you better show some resp fact
wow no one speaks zest that way oh my goodness
you expect us to sit back and take your insent bra
display love how classical this was whoa atude two
genres okay awesome cuz no one could
respect I want her outfit
so bad I have her hair my
god
without like how you learn who the characters
are via the songs oops I strike a nerve Angel
it's like Epic Rap Battles your wrinkled face
was turning red and why are you avoiding War
that's what the guns you sell are for yeah
one thing I'm to suspect Angel's head you have
disclosure what does she know reminds
me of Epic Rap Battles of History the
characters are so well flushed out but they're
so well like attuned in the do in the lyrics
Mother that's interesting what you little egg
creature I have a job for you follow them he's
like Alice in Wonderland he's like the he's like
the Mad Hatter no no the eggs no activity requires
more no bond stronger than those
formed through Bond hey it's a
fair point I mean you might need like
radical unconventional methods to get
this to work though you know I I don't
hate this I'm ready to punish some bad
boys okay hello there hi it's like a Medusa head
can't believe I let you drag us here angel it's
no big deal just need to teach them the way
I was taught this is how you learn to trust
people there is nothing stronger than the
trust between comrades and arms buckle up
buttercups because today you boys become men
oh boy wait I can't fight without my minions
are going to survive together and you are going
to make this hotel work oh there's totally Vibes
between them they're both gay aren't they the
women yeah there are other ways it just takes
time time we don't have how many times will
we have to watch your people be killed before
we make Headway I took charge today and it
all went sideways I'm supposed to make your
dreams reality I'm supposed to protect you a I
love them fgy you're not you're not if I can't
help you what's the point of me whoa her whole
identity is in there was she created I don't
think she's created I think she just gets her
whole identity and protecting her she gets her
purpose from that yeah I don't know though like
maybe Lilith hired her or something like maybe
she's incentivized or something I don't know
usually your instincts are right about these
things I don't know I did what I had to
do I am not disgusted got sing this what
whats on your soul friend this going to be
like a serious song sh the that's what she
said Angel why not your strength known
was I don't think it was it I didn't
think but that I would keep blood off
my face but when that thing attacked oh
[__] I had to she think she killed it
and maybe really they killed it I don't
know suppress the hope that they
would have a chance to win the
war oh nice this is like a rock
opera this this is awesome ballad
build imagine going to hell and having
kids that then meet you in hell you'd
be so bummed they ended up in hell but
stoked oh yeah yeah cuz they're with
you place and it felt so good to be
understood that's all people want
really a great
line just think about how I would do
cosplay her like I put the red tape
over my hair yeah you mess up your
hair for the sake of Cosplay worth
it I love how this is turned into a duet over
two very different things but it's all in the
Name of Love the old guy was a you're not yourself
you're the one that killed the Angel and the she
was whatever it takes screw your patient let's
keep this between us you got it boss super Mad
Hatter I'm I'm sorry I got so crazy today it's
okay no I'm sorry no you're Charlie you're not
sorry that's why you show up to the videos
guys comedic genius look what your exercise
did for them look they're getting along the
abondon with the dismembered arm yes that
was particularly unpleasant I like that
part at least you can take a beaten like
a champ you did a okay little kid you got
respect now thank you for pulling me out of
there I like the change they did with
this character a lot the snake one yeah
cuz he was kind of just generic before made
something really interesting how was your
day with aliser my minions I went to this
meeting and there was a knife lady an old
guy that's nice and the knife lady killed an
angel that took all of two seconds oh I'm so
sure and maybe you'll meet martians tomorrow but
now it's time for oh my God you think it's going
to click in a second oh ah yeah I'll end
on that nope oh no way they subverted our
expectations thank you to America's number one
meal kid hellofresh for partnering with us it's
always great to partner people whose Services
you actually use because as someone like me who's
always juggling a pack schedule between filming
and editing finding time for healthy eating can
be a challenge that's where hellofresh has been
a game changer for my life with hellofresh I get
farm fresh pre-portioned ingredients and delicious
recipes delivered right to my doorsteps so I don't
have to step outside it's revolutionized my home
cooking experience making it not just easy but
super enjoyable and affordable keyw I recently
tried their delicious barbecue pineapple flat RADS
and their zucchini pomodora Panet baked both were
mouthwatering delicious and fit perfectly with my
pescatarian lifestyle pescatarian M sounds fancy
and asking my friends who love meat hellofresh
has an incredible variety tempts me to be a meat
eater again people I know I've really recommended
their lemon parsley chicken palard I think is how
you pronounce it in the fuo chicken fajo tacos
regardless hellofresh menu has something for
everyone but of course it's not just about the
food it's about saving time too not having a wait
in line at a grocery store even self checkouts on
fast enough these days the convenience of having
everything delivered pre-portioned right to your
door is priceless especially with her quick and
easy meals like 15-minute recipes spending less
time in the kitchen and more time doing what
I love which is filming and editing so here's
the deal if you want a great way to support
the channel and also support you know having
a new lifestyle healthy affordable lifestyle in
the year 2024 go to hellofresh.com rejects free
and use code rejects free for free breakfast
for life you heard that right one breakfast
item per box while the subscription is active free
breakfast for life for hellofresh.com reject free
use promo code reject free try it out and let me
know your favorite is stay healthy and let's keep
enjoying those movies and shows all right reject
Nation let's get real for a moment running this
channel is incredible but managing finances
especially taxes and budgeting both for the
channel and my personal life can be overwhelming
that's where rocket money has been a financial
Lifesaver for me even before I ever partnered up
with them like I said I've been very fortunate to
be working with Brands whose products I already
use so it's a win-win for him walk but it can be
a win-win for you too cuz there's a reason I use
them rocket money is a personal finance app that
simplifies managing money by canceling unnecessary
subscriptions lowering bills and crafting a budget
that fits your specific lifestyle for someone
like me who can easily lose track of expenses
throughout every single day of the month
it's been eye openening to see where I was
overspending stuff I don't use that I kept paying
for especially apps man I was way too many apps
rocket money does a heavy lifting by analyzing
your spending then customizes notifications to
help you stay within your budget goals it's not
just about saving money it's about actively seeing
and feeling your financial progress It's a great
feeling they track your monthly subscriptions too
so many free trials I've signed up for that I
forgot to you know get rid of before the free
trial was done making it super easy to cancel
the ones you don't use couple of clicks and
you're putting money back in your pocket telling
you have you ever found hidden subscriptions or
pay for services you forgot about because Rocky
money is a huge asset in helping to uncover those
and even negotiated some of my bills down to
like 20% so if you're ready to take control
of your finances and there's no better time than
now because it is the beginning of the year check
out rocket money and see how much you could be
saving stop wasting money on things you do not use
so to help support the channel and help support
your wallet visit rocket money / rejects rocket
money currently has over 5 million users and has
helped save its members an average of $720 a year
with over $500 million in canceled subscriptions
they've helped me and I'm confident they'll do
the same for you that's rocket money.com rejects
your bank account will thank you they are lovers
confirmed who Charlie and what's the friend's name
bestie is that her name B oh vaggy vaggie Vagabond
yeah it should be the easiest name to remember
like pull but then you got to like kind of work
the brain like oh yeah vaggy yeah yeah no they are
they really do give me and I don't mean like they
stole it because obviously like it's they've made
it their own but it's really truly Harley Quinn
and Poison Ivy and I want them to get it on like
Donkey Kong yeah me too I want to see it on camera
I want the power Dynamic could be difficult we
going to see how they make it work because clearly
poison ivy is obsessed with Harley Quinn and the
scenario but I just want to make sure that Harley
has the same kind of feelings for poison iy yeah
I don't get the sense that Charlie actually has
the feelings that's the part I don't feel it from
Charlie the way that I do from Vagabond well is it
vagi or vaggie vaggie vaggy hard G yeah yeah yeah
cuz sometimes I think they're using the homophobic
slur and I'm like that's not what they're saying
with an F oh yeah was like just you're just such a
good person you couldn't think of it yeah well it
was cuz the why at the end like I I don't hear it
like that yeah yeah no yeah I I know I get what
you're saying now it's just like I have to hear
the V hear the V yeah yeah I mean um can you
hear the V with him uhhuh I think that I don't
know where it's going to end up with them but in
terms of like the immediate Journey at hand um I
like how it what they've really been evolving to
in other ways like we saw it with me we've been
seeing it with media of the political intricacies
and then with this episode you're seeing more
of like this high class secret society the ones
who really control secret society secret society
secret society within hell like with the secret
meetings and stuff I'm super curious how each of
those gets invited to the meeting because we do
like it's old money and it's new money in terms
of we see that guy put some respect on his name
tall dude and then the girl that was standing up
for him but then the girl that I want to be who's
got pigtails she's like uh yo I am new school and
this is crazy what's her name with the v no idea
Valencia Valerie vaggie no not her pigtails vager
V I think it's just V just V she's like uh no
I disagree and we should go start a war and is
that rash I don't know but it is it's interesting
see you everybody at the table who's that dinosaur
person need to know more about the dinosaur
yeah they have created a whole world I give
a crap about about every single character I want
to know how we got here I'm still thinking about
where Lilith is I'm still thinking about how
why uh our our dude the devil dude devil radio
dude is was gone for seven years now people are
just like well we're welcoming you back uh but
he was questioned on that by he was but then she
was like it was fine demonic entity guy yep what
I love too with this one is they had like such a
variety of music I said It reminds me of EP epic
rap battles of history have you ever seen them
yeah because what what's so cool about that is
like yeah they write the RS and they verse each
other but they're also I yeah but I haven't you
haven't Epic Rap Battles of History haven't heard
them no yes to heard of it no to seen it it is and
I said yeah really quick but then I just wanted
you to know that was a lie I appreciate your
honesty yeah no seriously and you don't get that
too often in life anymore people just kind of lie
especially on camera people feel like they got to
know everything but sometimes I don't [__] ain't
no [__] but hos and tricks you have to bring
down the rest of your sex in order to you know
oh no no [__] is not um specific to women is it
no not pry sure when I say it I only use it as a
derogatory term towards women oh but you can't say
vaggy I have a hard time where it's going to come
across differently when I say it out uhhuh uhhuh
uhhuh uhhuh but the music you were liking cuz
rap battles epic rap battles of history so what
they'll do is they'll take like two characters
you know like Indiana Jones versus uh Han Solo
and then they write raps versus it's just like a
rap battle but it's within the characters of them
with the same actor no no I usually get different
actors and oh you just picked the same actor
they just took two the same characters I mean
two different characters who happen to be played
by the same actor just slow it down all right so
they verse each other and and what they'll so
like Indiana Jones will like um you know dish
out insults about Han Solo and Han Solo it's like
a rap battle so it's very character driven at the
same time and I think that's what they do a lot
with with these kind kind of Duets not a duet
but when they're especially when they like this
slice of genre where one starts off kind of like
a classical Opera ballad and then the other one
goes into like hip-hop or something of that nature
when they're I love the verses of that and then
you get something that is like a duet where you
have people on two very different sides of town
coming from different angles but also rooted in
a similar emotion of love and protection uh with
characters who haven't even interacted with each
other but you get to see the similarities here
and that's the kind of thing that could could
lead to a reform like I I really feel like they're
building into something that's I think it's really
easy to look at the show and just see you know
the like oh look how Vivid the colors are and
how expression of this is and that's all grandiose
there there always seems like there's something a
little bit deeper underneath the surface here
because we have gotten a lot more political in
the way the world is being built out and then
you even get a character who I don't know what
that character is the one who everyone feared when
they were taking the cell phone photos and stuff
and Guy yeah tall creepy guy like all of his
lines were serious everyone every line he had
just truly seemed like a guy from a different
time period and and the way he spoke with such
uh the deboner qualities all this elegancy and
you're using some really good vocab words right
now Greg really oh no I lost it oh you like the
tall guy yeah I like big big guy big dude big big
big big big dra guy yeah I lo uh I loved uh the
way he was flushed out and I think they' done an
excellent job there and somehow what I what I
think is really clever about what the show has
done is they have I'm doing totally this symbol
here lizard people what about lizard people don't
say too what your's gonna call the lizard people
this calls lizard people maybe I thought this is
the Kanye West diamonds in the sky oh no is
that on it I like to are you threatening me
Jewish friend have you heard of Connie yeah
once or twice I don't know what his opinion
is about Jews but this is what he do okay but uh
um are they doing this in two batches for before
what were we saying what was I saying before the
Kanye was you were so off the tracks I don't even
know where you were going with the tall was on the
tracks and then you started saying lizard people
because you told said this is what I'm doing with
my hands I know I got distracted by myself yeah U
but you were saying you like the tall guy and
people were scared of him anyway good episode
yeah I guess you didn't love it I just felt like I
had a point I want to get out all right well think
about it take a second matter of fact you should
take four one two three yes I remember my God I
got it it's that the fact that they have this
storyline where you're going to the other side
of town with Alistair and you're you're learning
about oh they're they're keeping this really
hidden like At first it's a mystery of who killed
this Exorcist but then they want to suppress that
because if they know there's a chance of winning
not even a chance of winning they the people in
charge really think there's no chance of winning
and they don't want to give people hope at a
chance of like some type of Revolution right and
that's a completely bigger story and and a whole
other area to explore then you keep cutting back
to the hasbin hotel immediacy of that which is a
little bit more comical but that's where you get
something that is more emotional and I like that
the thing that tethers them together is the thing
that is the countdown to the extermination um is
that what they're calling it The purging the
cleansing whatever is is the countdown to it
but they're they feel like completely different
types of stories yet the marriage of them is so
well done yeah like you're saying there's a lot
of different layers to it like do the people in
charge in Hell not want people to know that
she was capable of kill an angel because they
don't think they're capable of winning the
war and they don't want their people to get
hurt or is it because they don't want to give
them the Hope or is it because they're scared
that they're going to do an uprising too many of
them are going to die and then hell is going to be
weaker or they're scared that some of them are
actually going to escape and then they'll less
con constituents in hell like there there's got to
be all different motives and because of Alistair I
still not knowing what's up with him I feel like
he's going to be the big twist of the season I
I and I I don't fully trust him we have to know
what is he doing here what does he know and now
he has this information from eggy so what's he
going to do with that who's he report back to is
it Lilith yeah I think you're right I think it's
lth well let's see what episode four reveals to
us guys for schore and has been a hotel ago this
is why Roxy is a TV girl she's here provide good
commentary like that um leave your thoughts down
below about uh if you were to send someone that
you know in in your personal life to Hell who
would it be uh that's my YouTube question for
the day and tag them tag them Time the video all
right well uh we'll see you guys for episode four
Maria Hammond Maria it was your birthday recently
so wanted to say happy birthday to you and for
2024 we got to send you a gift yes we do what are
we realistically going to send her a puppy no uh
your responsibility we don't want it we found it
on the street take it please take it is it alive
we just packed it in a UPS box taped it sh yes
like fragile there's a bowl of water hopefully it
doesn't fall over spill all over this thing um oh
goodness we could get her something commemorative
we can name a star after her that's not a bad
gift John you know I'm saying like I mean of
all things to commemorate your cost more than
what she pays every month for undoubtedly so
you know what will have to financial if you
can increase your pledge so we can get you
this St yeah I think you only have to pay for it
once so like you know you don't subscribe to the
star unfair see what you did you wanted the star
and now you just took advantage of us may it seem
like you forging and now we got to give you a
gift once you fully paid off your gift thanks
but seriously app we got we got to get you some
it I'm already thinking about it but no thank
you for being such an amazing human being here's
to another 78 more years of minimum enjoying not
saying you're 78 I was just throwing out a random
number just to stay alive for at least lives past
like 80 on average right yeah it's like the going
rate right now what is the average person Maria
let's make this really fun for your birthday
what is the average mortality yeah John type
it in what is the average mortality rate
what is the a average I really don't know
how3 okay so we're getting close 7316 years
according to quora okay the average life
expectancy in the world right now hope
I hope you be the first person what is
the oldest person I've ever lived
who's the old 70 actually 70 years
for men and 75 for women yeah okay they
got less problems that's why that's right
much more relaxed life what is the oldest
person how old is the current oldest the
world oh you can beat them all right Maria they're
only 116 years old they live in Spain their name's
also Maria oh my God holy [__] it was meant to
be Maria you got to be the new dominant extended
life Maria yes if you could just make it to
118 I think you got a good amount of distance
between the next runner up so we're going to
do whatever it takes that's what we're going
to do we're going to send you an IV we're going
to get you cry Frozen we're going to uh send you
some vitamins we're going to get you some uh
oh oh that whatever it takes to get you that
baby blood stuff that people are always freaking
out about yeah people talk about quality of life
not quantity hell with that I don't care how
miserable you get I don't care if you develop
some debilitating disease over the next couple
years and you're just like oh my God just put
me out of my misery no we will trap you we're
going to get you that hydrochrome even if we
have to just keep your head alive in a tank like
Futurama we will do it to make sure you make it
to that's your gift that's your GI put your head
over here is not letting you die yes your gift
is forced immortality it's good so yeah happy
birthday Maria love you love you you've been
an absolute gem in our lives and you you know
damn well that we know that so thank you my
dear